hey there hello friends [__] we lost
Ravi we're here in Warsaw in beautiful
Poland my self a 90 flew over just
couple days ago to play The Witcher 3
Wild Hunt we're working on a bunch of
video features for those which will be
available on gamespot calm in a couple
of weeks but Rock I'll talk about that
right now
first of all I want to talk to you about
something that's been on my mind since
we got here on the flight over I was
reading this book the last wish which is
the first of the books in The Witcher
series that the games are based on and
in this one chapter that I found
interesting the protagonist of both the
book and the game is Geralt of Rivia is
put in this rather interesting
marlee ambiguous situation where he's
forced to choose what he believes is the
lesser of two evils well things don't
work out quite as Geralt expected as
much like in life we don't always know
how our actions would affect the world
but the thing is in games we mostly do
but more crucially we want to we find
satisfaction in learning of video games
rules and systems and by mastering them
so if gamers need to see the puppet
strings how can we create truly
realistic morally ambivalent human
worlds the point season 3 episode 9 game
design vs. believable human worlds video
games are systems systems of rules and
objectives every game gives us an
objective and it's by understanding the
rules of the game world that we achieve
them so much like sports or games of any
kind an important part of video game
design is ensuring that the user
understands the system and understand
how their interactions where they're
packed on it we like to know how much
damage the weapon wheels the best place
to build the roads or the attack
patterns that enemies use our ability to
understand these systems and to master
them is fundamentally connected with our
enjoyment of these games we want our
enemies in video games to be intelligent
but not too intelligent
we like to learn their patterns so we
can anticipate what they'll do and it's
when they stray from these patterns that
we get frustrated I mean things can have
an element of randomness but only as
long as the parameters for randomness
are specifically defined we like to
watch when the dice rolls this is all
well and good in video games but life
isn't like a game of chess even the best
player of life
predict 12 moves ahead this isn't an
issue with lots of games shooters sports
games fighting games strategy games I
mean we play these experiences because
of their systems we enjoy them and learn
them and get better at them in fact it's
only when we really start to drag human
emotions and experiences into the mix
that our desire to understand the game
systems clashes with our desire for
realism an easy example of this might be
the Walking Dead games when we first
played these games there was a
notification system for important
decisions turned on by default so
anytime you made a meaningful choice in
the game it would tell you that
Clementine would remember that the
problem with showing this was that it
immediately made all other decisions in
the game entirely less important almost
irrelevant really the only thing making
all of your interactions with the game's
characters feel Ajith Amit was the idea
that you didn't know when they were
important you didn't know what things
they cared about you couldn't see the
system's
boss turning off this notification meant
turning off your ability to see the
game's puppet strings to learn how the
game works and to try and make the best
decisions and we as gamers have real
trouble with this one
the suicide mission in Mass Effect 2 is
a good example this was a game that had
optional character missions that helped
you get to know your crew better some of
these stories were absolutely incredible
but as far as you know they didn't
really impact on the main mission it
wasn't until later the folks started to
realize that it was by completing these
side missions that you had a much better
chance of having your individual crew
members survive the games haunting final
mission and what did many of us do when
we realized this did we accept that
reality some did but many others loaded
up their old save game and went back to
complete the missions as much as we want
realistic systems that are unpredictable
the temptation to be the best that a
game is often too much but there are a
few games that do succeed in delivering
unexpected results that gamers find
satisfying for a series based so much
about completing objectives the world of
Fallout does a fantastic job at
obfuscating the rules of the world and
it does this by having so many systems
that you never really have your eye on
all of them do you need to kill someone
well you could shoot them or lure them
into an area with lots of their enemies
you could give them too many stimpacks
and watch them die of toxicity or maybe
use your speech to convince them to kill
themselves maybe you don't have that
maybe you have a bomb why not reverse
pickpocket them and put that live bomb
in their pockets or if you're
underpowered don't kill them at all kill
the person who gave you the contract the
ability for a game to give you different
ways of completing an objective even if
they're not the best ones is something
we really appreciate as game fans like
the books The Witcher franchise does a
great job of making results unknowable
quests which allow players choices but
give unexpected results confuse our
moral compasses and make the world feel
less rigid and predictable than we
previously thought players love learning
systems you only enough to look at the
popularity of dota and hearthstone to
see that but it's when games don't
deliver the results we expect that they
feel more real and when that happens we
don't care if we really met our
objective or got the best results
because the moment itself was its own
reward you can't be the best all the
time that's not how life works and it's
when games successfully add that into
the equation that they feel more human
more real it's all well and good playing
the hero but isn't it more fun when
you're not really sure which way the
moral compass is pointing
I was certainly the case in fallout on
The Witcher and it's probably the case
in The Witcher 3 right well myself and
Andy were lucky enough to play the game
that combines let's say 12 hours this
week and we're working on a bunch of
features we'll be on GameSpot calm and
at just a couple of weeks so make sure
you check back then in the meantime Gen
queer I'm gonna get back to my books oh
my god he's having sex with everyone
[Music]